[Musique]
alors que les états unis traversent
actuellement une intense période de
révoltes suite à la mort d'un homme noir
lors d'une bavure policière à
minneapolis le monde entier se saouler
progressivement pour s'indigner contre
le racisme qui gangrène nos sociétés
c'est le sujet sur lequel les
dessinateurs du magazine satirique
charlie hebdo qu'ont décidé de réagir
cette semaine avec un dessin qui à peine
sorti fait déjà beaucoup réagir un
dessin sur lequel on peut voir donald
trump sur le sol dans la même position
que john floyd
l'homme victime de la bavure policière
en train de se faire tuer par un
policier une une qui comme d'habitude ne
laisse personne indifférent alors qu'est
ce que vous en pensez qu'ils aiment
qu'ils n'aiment pas jean-michel moi
j'aime pas je pourrais même pas dire je
suis choqué je ne la comprends pas je
vois pas où est l'humour je vois pas où
est le message c'est quoi le projet de
cette course est une compagnie croate
égalité c'est bien qu'on veut c'est
compréhensible si les zones non vous
êtes quand même un peu annonce qu'on va
match contre ces patrons qui
responsables des violences tous deux
policières donc pourquoi et un policier
qui lui met la truck je vois assez bien
sûr que oui mais messi mais mais non
mais là la jean-michel je comprends pas
bah oui c'est rob comme celle ci c'est
le symbole a bien entendu et comme
symbole je le dis à jean michel vous
êtes un grand joueur et c'est pourquoi
c'est une lutte entre la police et la
musique
alors j'aurai fallait qui est
responsable d'une unité 6 dure depuis
cent ans 200 autres mais si l'impact moi
mais c'est un symbole avec toutefois la
décision qu'il a pris ses tweets qui ont
été censurés qui a incité à la haine et
la violence surnom est normal qu'elle
affréterait bien j'en ai parlé trois
quarts sur le tour à mon avis vous avez
parlé à des gens qui voient là bas alors
qu'ils aiment qu'ils n'aiment pas s'il
vous plaît il adore moi et je déteste
ces chalets d'eux met en revanche
contrat et je comprends ce que tu veux
dire mais contrairement à toi je trouve
que c'est franchement pas la pire qu'ils
aient fait sam aussi chaussé de crampons
nettement il a dit tellement de
conneries en 48 heures et en 72 heures
pour se concentrer sur les deux derniers
jours que honnêtement je peux comprendre
cette lutte et qu' ils ont fait bien
pire et graphiques jeu sur le temps est
bon ils ont fait bien pire aussi je suis
d'accord je suis pas extrêmement choquée
moi par par cette une voie là je le dit
bernard montiel
moi j'ai pas du tout choquée voilà un
message est très clair et même si la
chatte viennent de censurer
trump qui arrête pas de dire que des
conneries c'est twitter qui l'attend oui
au 6 mai soit aussi oui absolument il a
balancé des messages insupportable qui
entraîne de la haine et la violence donc
là c'est normal parce qu'on a envie de
lui faire ça un train part en réalité on
peut pas on peut pas incitent à la haine
on peut pas dire on peut pas combattre
la haine mais symbolise pas d'accord
avec vous mais symbole en nature je suis
pas d'accord et un mondial auquel tu vas
dire ça qu'on peut être mais en tout cas
voilà on comprend le message à tous pour
l'état c'est ça est ce que vous voulez
mais où est-ce que vous l'aimez pas
kelly qui voulait pour la parole là moi
j'aurais aimé plus de plus d'humour et
plus d'originalité je m'attendais à
mieux de le ca à l'épaule
oui je trouve pas ça d'un les potes que
drôle et puis ça me fait un rappel à ce
geste que je veux plus voir et qu'on
veut plus voir nulle part alors sur
hazard je suis assez d'accord c'est vrai
que ce geste là on n'a plus envie de le
voir c'est ça donc là ça nous rappelle
ce geste là il y avait accepté sur mêmes
ils ont pris le même faciès que le ainsi
on n'a pas envie de le voir en une
aujourd'hui le policier qui a tué
georges lot y en a pas on a pas du voir
sa tronche en fait non mais c'est vrai
on n'a pas du tout envie de voir le
politique a tué jean claude ont une voix
là de charlie hebdo c'est vrai que voilà
ça c'est un petit peu maladroit voilà
donc c'est pour ça on sent voilà j'aime
pas la une
après le symbole donald trump je peux le
comprendre
voilà gilles mais je vais au bout de
votre logique moi c'est ce qui me gêne
c'est que ce geste là maintenant des
joueurs de foot peuvent le faire quand
il ya personne en dessous de poser le
genou en hommage
mais là c'est pas un hommage à une
incitation à la haine voire à plus c'est
ce qu'elle fait à l'encontre à
l'encontre de trump et donc c'est faire
son jeu parce que lui et dans la
violence la presse et faire son je le
vois faire son jeu et comment ces
tunnels est totalement ratée pas drôle
et à la fois elle va dans le sens de
-trop - ne me choque profondément dans
la comprend une wii sofico non mais moi
je trouve que ça manque terriblement de
nuance c'est à dire qu'à un moment donné
et et charlie hebdo depuis un moment en
fait ça manque vraiment nuancé à dire
qu'à chaque fois on s'attend à une une
qui devrait normalement charlie hebdo ça
va être drôle c'est un journal satirique
on est là en fait s'est engagée d'une
manière politique c'est pas tout à fait
drôle et pas tout à fait film donc tout
violences policières on veut l'égalité
en écrasant trame de cette manière je
suis pas certaine qu'il va se passer un
message
qu'ils soient le bon enfin me pardonne
moi c'était de cette f1 charlie hebdo à
abc recensons c'est un autre débat il
avait eu ma chérie c'est là à la raison
ceux ci est un journal satirique
intelligent et un peu faim je suis
désolée la belle oui c'est ça ça sans
s'attirer qu'intelligents et un bref un
et ça fait des années maintenant qu'ils
ne sont plus du tout parce que le
journal est en difficulté qui cherche à
faire le buzz et quand je vous entends
dire la une à l'épaté allait pas si
méchante que ça on a vu pire
il n'y a pas de jérôme géométrie
variable pour moi c'est une à cette lune
et c'est une la halle est dégueulasse
comme les autres une qu'ils ont fait
auparavant
tu peux pas à souhaiter la mort de
donald trump avec le genou même si
donald trump c'est pas ma tasse de thé
je n'aime pas du tout c'est pas mon pays
je suppose t j je suis là je n'aime pas
du tout il a été il a été élu les gens
l'ont élu les gens ont voté
c'est pour ça que c'est important le
vote on l'a on le dit autrefois je le
redis encore ici le vote c'est très
important et les américains il faut
qu'ils aillent voter aussi c'est
important
moi c'est une là elle me va pas du tout
je n'aime pas du tout je dis pas qu'elle
est légère que j'aime bien il ya des
gens qui l'ont vu j'ai parlé que des
gens ils m'ont dit la une de charlie
hebdo les mortels jeu mais sauf qu'elle
est bien celle là mais les autres une
qu'ils ont fait les fois démonté mais
pas celle là aussi je n'aime pas autant
que les autres pour moi c'est à dire
charles et buzz en train de se perdre et
ça cherche le buzz parce que ça veut
vendre des trucs je pense que c'est un
peu cela dit c'était satirique
intelligent et là ils se perdent
beaucoup encore le truc tu es à moi je
vous le dis ça me dérange le plus c'est
de revoir le faciès de phase iib flic
mal à moi j'ai pas du tout envie de voir
franchement ils voient l'accès sable ça
me voilà ça se joue 10 et ça me met donc
ça me met en rogne voilà de morsay c'est
vrai que voilà alors il ya un autre truc
qui qui qui fait qui a fait apparition
sur les réseaux sociaux dont croyais que
c'était une blague au début plusieurs
adolescents sont filmés en train de
reproduire la scène de l'arrestation de
georges floyd ou croyez vraiment que
c'était un fake et regarder en fait non
regardez ça ressemble à ça c'est le
floyd challenge mais qu'est-ce que ça
franchement alors ça ça aussi s'y
refaire déjà qu'on appelle le floch
challenge non mais c'est franchement au
douar ça bien sûr un stade ça ça devient
n'importe quoi ça voilà je vous le dis
je le dis à un stage le dia twitter
jeudi aux réseaux sociaux
il est parfois il bloque des gens qui
font des petites réflexions et ça on
laisse passer
je suis désolé ça c'est un exemple
dégueulasse pour la jeunesse et ça c'est
id admis
de montrer ça voilà je vous le dis
franchement ça pourquoi regarder en plus
avec le sourire comment peut rigoler de
staff je suis désolé ça vraiment je le
dis au modérateur d'instagram études et
autres réseaux sociaux sur ça ça c'est
inadmissible et tu peux pas laisser
passer ça c'est lyon même quand tu vois
le floyd show late son truc ils doivent
être alertés ils doivent arrêter ça tout
de suite quand tu vois comme ça je suis
désolé ça c'est dégueulasse après un
stage facebook et tous ces gens là ils
ont adressé une responsabilité énorme
vous aimez quatre images qu'on voit là
moi qu'est-ce qui vous qu'est-ce qui
vous pourquoi j'ai à chaque fois je vous
dis je n'aime pas l'huile sur le feu à
chaque fois je vous réponds ça je n'aime
pas l'huile sur le feu y'a pas de black
dans les quatre images comme par hasard
c'est que des jeux assez d'accord ça
m'énerve parce que qu'est ce qu'ils vont
dire les gens regardent ces des blancs
qui s'amusent encore regarde exactement
alors qui sait ça divise avec ccsa
divisé ça fait peur et un star facebook
et tout ça et même le gouvernement
américain pour calmer jeu ça les mettre
là il ya les noms il ya tout ce qui
c'est les mecs vraiment donner un
support tu peux pas laisser passer ça
ils sont à vomir c'est mais pas vraiment
je voulais en parler à nos
téléspectateurs ce soit vraiment ça ne
le fait pas c'est nul
moi je veux juste vous montrer la vidéo
la plus touchante du jour c'est la fille
de george floyd qui a pris la parole sur
les épaules d'un ancien joueur de nba il
ya seulement six ont écouté ce qu'elle
dit c'est juste magnifique ça voilà ça
voilà ça c'est la classe
voilà quel gâchis
[Musique]
c'était une image magnifique c'était ça
déchire la brise le coeur à la six ans
elle a pu te papa parce que son papa
était par terre neutralisé avec 3 je
vais pas j'ai pas envie d'en supprimer
pour un mec il était l'autre anisé ya
pas d excuse moi sophie il était au sol
l'autre à l'autre alizés injuste a dû
mettre les menottes et fils dans une
bagnole ils remettent devant la justice
pour les 6es ou 10,3 à bruit énorme et
un boum c'était pire que ça c'est pour
ça que les criminels
on espère que ça c'est des assassins et
tu leur mets devant la justice et j'ai
entendu les arguments
ouais il avait déjà fait de la prison
c'est pas grave s'il doit faire dix fois
de la prison c'est la justice qui décide
s'il doit aller en prison dix fois il
irradie fois mais c'est pas pour ça
qu'on doit enlever la vie à quelqu'un
les débats que j'ai entendu oui mais il
avait pris ses il avait pris de la
cocaïne ceci cela je m'en fous vous le
mettez en prison c'est la juste c'est
pas la police et la justice qui doit
juste c'est bon sociaux fille sous peu
sur ellis ouvrage sondage merci
j'aime la une de charlie hebdo à 39% je
n'aime pas 61% et je pense que les 61%
des personnes qui ont dit qu'ils
n'avaient pas c'est surtout parce qu'on
ne veut plus voir le faciès de ce
policier cre pour nous un meurtrier